blheli32esc's just got a big performance
upgrade the devs have introduced a
feature called by rpm variable pwm
frequency and although that name may not
suggest much to you it is one of the
biggest leaps in smoothness torque
braking performance it is one of the
biggest leaps in performance for blhe32
escs since they came out
so in this video we're going to go over
what that feature is
why you want to be using it how to know
if your esc is actually going to be able
to support it and as long as we're on
the topic let's just take a look at
blj32 esc's in this day and age and talk
about how you should be picking them and
how you should be setting them up i'm
joshua bardwell and you're going to
learn something today the first thing
you need to know about this awesome new
feature is that you want to be on the
latest version of blheli32 in order to
use it
blheli32 had a thing called variable pwm
frequency but the by rpm is the thing
you really want and i think it's 32.8.3
that added that so let's go ahead and
download the latest version of bail
hilly suite and make sure we've got that
by the way if you have blheli s you're
not going to be able to use this exact
feature but you still can improve the
performance of your blheli s escs by
flashing a firmware called bluej i've
got a video about that i'm going to put
it down in the video description and
if you're not running bla32 you should
probably go watch that instead
rip my retention graph
the simplest way to download blheli
suite is to go to this google drive link
which i'll have linked in the video
description as always
and i'm going to download let's see i'm
running windows so i guess i want
blhillysweet3232812.zip
by the way blhelisweet1671
is for bl healthy s esc's you want
blheli suite 32. i'll go ahead and
download that
and when that download completes i'm
going to get a zip file with these
contents and you don't there's no
installer you just put it in a folder on
your hard drive and i've already got
that folder so i'm just going to replace
that stuff but i'm going to leave the
music folder behind which has my startup
tones
i'll just drag this
and copy it over
and then i'll just double-click blheli
suite32.exe to get that going and here
we are on the latest i guess it's
32.8.1.2 hey there folks it's joshua
from the future don't let the fact that
i'm wearing a different shirt and i've
cut my hair confuse you i'm just
recording this on a different day the
next thing we're going to do is we're
going to
plug in our quadcopter and we're going
to plug in our flight controller to usb
and then here in blheli suite we're
going to select the correct com port
that appears and connect
and when once it connects we're going to
hit
read setup and what we're going to look
for here is this
text string if bl324 in one we need that
information because in order to get this
by rpm functionality we have to download
a pre-release and not yet released
firmware at least at the time that i'm
doing this at some point in the future
wait i thought i was joshua from the
future well
he's joshua from the far future
at some point in the future you will be
able to just go to this esc flash
tab and right here will be 32.8.3 which
is the firmware version we want today is
not that day though so we are going to
go to this github repo and we are going
to go
into the rev 32.8.3 test code folder
and here we are going to look for the
hex file that has that same name as the
uh esc name that we saw here iflight
bl3241
and the simplest thing to do is just hit
ctrl f and search
bl 32 4 in one
there is
bl324196k and bl3241 multi32
i'm not sure which of those is right so
let's download both of them
the next little quirk in this
process is that downloading files from
github is
confusing and not intuitive so what i'm
going to do is i'm just going to click
on this to go into this page
and that actually isn't going to
download the file to download the file
i'm going to need to right click on the
raw button and do save link as and
here's what you need to do don't just
save this to your downloads folder or
your desktop
go to the place where you installed
blheli
blheli suite
and in that folder
there is a folder blhe32 hex files that
is where you're going to want to save
this hex file
and then after i've restarted blheli and
reconnected i'm going to go to the esc
flash tab and you should see here that
you have the option for 32.8.3 test
version external file and we're going to
flash the esc with the this firmware i
suggest that you do enable the keep
settings which will keep all your
settings your motor reversed basically
your motor direction is the one you're
most concerned with we'll just hit flash
selected esc and it will go through and
flash all four of those esc's now while
it's flashing the esc let's talk about
this new feature variable pwm frequency
and by rpm
when the esc drives the motor it doesn't
simply push a dc current through the
motor like it would with an older style
brushed motor it actually drives it with
a pwm pulse width modulated signal in
which the voltage goes up and down it's
actually a digital signal and the length
or width of those
high voltage pulses is what controls the
throttle the longer it leaves the
throttle of the signal at high voltage
the higher the throttle position and the
faster the motor spins
it turns out that the frequency of this
pwm signal has a significant effect on
motor performance
if we look at this chart from chris
rosser's recent video where he goes a
little bit more in depth into some of
the numbers behind what i'm talking
about here and i'll put a link to that
in the video description as well
we can see that as pwm frequency goes up
the efficiency of the motor goes up
and that's why wouldn't you want more
efficiency that means more power and
less battery usage and longer flight
times shouldn't we just run the highest
pwm frequency possible and the answer
that question is shown in this graph
from chris roster's video where he shows
that breaking performance significantly
reduces as pwm frequency goes up and it
turns out that one of the most important
characteristics for a mini quad motor
and esc
is the responsiveness
not neces because they're changing speed
all the time and the ability to change
speed very rapidly in response to
changing air conditions has a big big
influence on how well a quadcopter flies
so we don't run at maximum pwm frequency
uh because like as if it was an airplane
engine where you were just constantly at
80 percent throttle
just cruising higher pwn frequency would
be amazing but because we're constantly
changing speed we often run at a lower
pwm frequency even though it's hurting
our efficiency and this is where
variable pwm frequency comes in now that
the esc has finished flashing we can
reconnect and we can take a look at how
variable pwm frequency is configured in
blheli suite and we can see right here
that we have two options pwm frequency
low and pwm frequency high
and what that lets us do is set a
lower bound and a higher bound on the
pwm frequency that blheli will use and
then as the throttle input goes up the
pwm frequency increases
why would you want to do that well if
you think about it
you need the maximum braking performance
when you are lowering the throttle when
the motor is slowing down
and you need the maximum efficiency
and power when the throttle is up so the
idea is that when the throttle's down
you go to a low pwm frequency when the
throttle is up you go to a high
pedometer frequency and you get the best
of both worlds but there's a problem
with the way that blheli implemented
this until now
and the problem is that they tied it
simply to the throttle position and it
turns out that when you do that the pwm
frequency can interface or interact with
the
rpm of the motor
to create harmonics and those harmonics
can cause mid throttle oscillation jello
and other flight performance problems
thanks joshua from the past good job
what you're going to want to do is set
the pwm frequency low as low as possible
because you're going to want the maximum
torque and maximum braking performance
when you're at low rpm and then for pwm
frequency high you're going to move that
all the way to the right and it should
say by rpm and that's the feature that's
the buy rpm variable pwm feature that we
have gone to all this trouble to get
once you've done that you're just going
to hit write setup and
you probably are going to need to do
that for all four of your yes no it
seems to be
consistent for all of the esc that's
awesome
well that wasn't so hard was it okay it
was probably a little bit hard for some
people if you made it this far and if
i've helped you get access to this new
feature would you consider going down
and hit the like button that tells
youtube that this is a useful video that
more people need to see and i really
want as many people as possible to be
able to benefit from this really awesome
feature thank you so much for taking the
effort to do that it means a lot this is
the best performance that i think you're
going to get out of a blh32 esc today
but you need to be aware that not all
ascs are going to be able to take full
advantage of it the buy rpm feature
gives you great smoothness power and
efficiency at the high end great
responsiveness breaking torque at the
low end and no mid throttle oscillations
hopefully throughout the whole throttle
range but in order to fully take
advantage of it you need an esc that can
go
all the way down to like 16 or 24
kilohertz at the low end and all the way
up to like oh my god look at this do you
see that my esc only goes up to 48k
that is awful you want an esc that goes
up to 96 or even 128k i'm not really
getting the most of this feature
if you want to be able to buy an esc
that you are sure is going to be able to
take full advantage of this feature i
got another video i made that tells you
the specific specs that you want to look
for now i'm going to put it up on screen
in a little flyout card it
also tells you the other things about
esc's that you might want to look for
such as amp rating and voltage rating
and i hope you'll check that out as well
in the meantime though that's gonna do
it for this video thank you so much for
watching and happy flying